From a personal standpoint,
I like to think that I'm,
that I am making a contribution and
however big or however small it is,
what are,
what I'm trying to do is to help solve
major social problems.
That's what I want to do.
That's sort of my life's work,
if you will.
And I've worked very hard at this.
I've,
I've done it now for a long,
long time and I've worked on everything
from seat belt safety to a third world
development to the things that we do at
arp.
And I'm a couple of examples of
successes,
not me personally,
but that,
uh,
we've been able to have it.
ARP is that we get prescription drugs
into Medicare and you cannot practice
modern medicine without prescription
drugs.
So long term that's going to have a huge
payoff for our country and for our older
citizens.
Um,
a few years ago we fought the good fight
and we were able to prevent social
security from being privatized.
That for us was a big win and I think a
big win for the country.
So I'm,
I like to look at these a,
and there are plenty of,
of losses as well as wins.
Uh,
I'd like to look at these as steps
forward and hope that I made a
contribution to
the baby boomers have a huge
contribution.
In fact,
I wrote a book about it.
It's called 50 plus igniting a
revolution to reinvent America.
And what 50 plus is about is the fact
that the boomers have so much more to
contribute.
Uh,
they're going to leave a legacy.
They are,
they're making change.
Now in terms of working longer in terms
of,
uh,
you know,
what's happening in the marketplace.
Uh,
some of the other issues I talked about
in terms of healthcare and so forth,
the boomers,
uh,
have been catered to their whole lives.
They've reinvented every aspect of life.
They've gone through a,
they're going to reinvent retirement,
uh,
and they've got an attitude.
Okay.
Well,
the biggest I think is a lack of
political will that we talked about
before.
Trying to get the,
uh,
the policy changes we need to prepare
for an aging society.
Uh,
it's very difficult right now to see how
we can break that partisan gridlock that
we face in Washington and in many state
capitals.
Um,
and,
and part of it has to be that the public
has to demand change.
Uh,
so that's one of the things that is a
very tough for us to deal with,
but there are others as well.
For example,
um,
a lot of people are in this country
because they haven't been able to save
for retirement for whatever reason,
are going to be really dependent upon
social security.
And social security was not ever meant
to be an entire source of retirement
living.
It was meant to be a kind of a safety
net kind of a floor.
And so I'm helping people who need a
helping hand,
helping older people,
uh,
who are not going to be well off as many
boomers are,
is a key part of what we have to think
about.
Okay.